I had one question which is when I was a
kid one of my favorite things was
something you mentioned Mel Brooks
earlier your good friend and you two
wrote together of course for many years
and you've collaborated and you've been
best friends and I think you you get
together almost every night and watch
television
yes except now he's in London with
Frankenstein so I haven't seen her for
about a month and it's very terrible
yeah yeah I'll come over any time please
yeah here's my question my question is
you guys together did 2,000 year old man
and it was one of my favorite bits of
all time where and you were such a
brilliant straight man but you guys
would you interview Mel Brooks who
played the oldest man in the world 2,000
years old and I always heard that this
had a very unusual beginning that you
you weren't to writers who sat down and
worked it out that you guys would just
do this at parties and that's how it got
started
you know matter of fact the very first
time I saw Mel I didn't know who he was
I came to the show or she owes to be a
writer actor yeah and there was a guy
standing he was working for Sid for $35
a jokerz yeah it wasn't working for the
show and here I this man with the Jewish
accent saying you know how hard it is to
set sail these days yeah but it was a
Jewish pirate know how difficult it is
to set sail these days you know what
they're charging for sailcloth three
dollars and 40 cents a yard I can't
afford to fill it pillaging rape anymore
the first time I heard the next time I
came in to the office I said to him I I
just know where I said I understand sir
that you knew Jesus uh-huh
he's his thin lad right he wore sandals
walked around with 12 other guys nice
boy
they came into the store never bought
anything I can't picture of Jesus and
the Apostles they're hanging on the
store they don't buy anything we had can
we show a quick clip of you and now
doing 2000 year old man let's take a
look
was bullfights we have them today yes
well two big boobs but getting a ring
and kill each other to the love of
account
no no just a moment today a man in a
bullfight in the middle of a ring with a
love of a cow the cow was else yeah so
you guys
the interesting thing about that as we
did this at parties you just did it at
parties but for five years before we
ever put a week thought we first of all
it was the the Jewish accent was persona
non grata
Hitler had just made a mess of the world
right and with the Jewish accent was for
our friends of Jewish friends and Nam
they could be accepted by a larger
audience and non anti-semitic Gentile
friends right so we did the parties and
at one party it got to be so that people
who made special party so Milliken like
and uh and at one party there were these
a little hey level people and I'll never
forget George Burns was there and he
said is there an album on this we said
no he's just putting on an album or I'll
steal it and the second one was Edward G
Robinson oh yeah so like Jesus I'd like
to play that man on Broadway I'd like to
pray the thousand man yeah I'm Broadway
make a play out of it right played a
thousand Isis mm I could play any age it
was one of these guys who sat at a desk
bless his soul one of the great men
Steve Allen yeah who said I have this
world Pacific jazz studio he says you
guys take it over I want nothing to do
with but this should be on record and we
said no and he said do it we took the
studio did it for 300 people well for
about two and a half hours Adler being
cut it down to 47 minutes and because of
Steve Allen we're talking about it yeah
well it changed everything it's just
such a fantastic such a fantastic
routine I just cannot believe I mean in
today's culture with podcasts and with a
million different outlets something that
good wouldn't survive at parties for
five years growing and growing and
growing it doesn't I mean it was such a
different time yes I know
you